[Music]
today reviewing the AMD rx7800 XT this
is the 500 card that is coming to the
market uh we also have the 7700 XT it's
back there we're gonna have a separate
video on that coming out today as well
but this one is focused on the 78 XT so
for this benchmarking a couple things to
consider one is that as with everything
else this current generation there's a
lot of last gen cards that are still
very relevant and still available in a
lot of cases so we'll be looking at
those a little more closely than we
might for just say any other modern GPU
launch because there's a lot of options
in the 400 to 500 range secondly the
7700 XD is 450 there's only a 50 price
gap between this and the 77 which makes
that comparison particularly interesting
and that's why we want a separate video
to focus on it for this one though we're
going to look at the 78 including in
Star field
because we can't get away from that game
right now uh and let's get started
before that this video is brought to you
by Squarespace and visiting
squarespace.com Gamers Nexus will give
you 10 off your first purchase with them
we've built a number of our own websites
with Squarespace including our recently
launched gamers.nexis site where we list
catastrophic PC Hardware failures to
inform subscribers of those failures I
built this site personally in a couple
of hours by using squarespace's fluid
engine to move blocks around visually
until I liked it we also built our store
website with Squarespace using its
built-in e-commerce tools and of course
we built a website for our CEO snowflake
because she demanded our audience know
who really runs the show get to the core
of your idea and spend less time on web
design by signing up at squarespace.com
Gamers and access or click the link
below okay so full disclosure right up
front uh I am exhausted so is the team
we've been working non-stop on Benchmark
in Starfield Idaho boohoo uh no one
cares the reason that I'm mentioning
though is because it's actually pushed
us to finally put our our normal game
Benchmark charts into summary charts and
they're actually super cool they're
going to be at the end of this video and
the reason the exhaustion caused that is
because at the end of the process wrote
all the charts uh and then we kind of
looked at it and said so what do we
think
and we put together some summaries those
will be at the end because we've been
adding more and more games to our test
Suite including we've added Dying Light
2 and Resident Evil 4 and then of course
star field and so having those plus our
existing Suite uh we've got enough now
where we can put together an overall
percent improvement from card a versus
card b anyway those will be at the end
to help us make a decision so we can
come to conclusions now uh for this
setup here AMD thinks that this card is
the true successor to the rx6800 not the
6800 XT
the 6800 this is the 7800 XT so AMD has
chosen by name and marketing and
signaling to the customer to say this is
the successor but then sort of by spec
and in a sense MSRP pricing it's saying
that the 6800 non-xt is the original
predecessor to this we don't really care
about any of that because it's just
marketing what we care about is how it
performance of the 6800 XT because it's
the same price so we saw a couple that
are still available at least in the US
with some of the retailers we check and
looking at Newegg Amazon there's a few
listings for around 500 bucks plus or
minus twenty dollars that makes the 68
XT actually a direct competitor to the
78 XD while you can still get it and if
you're willing to deal with a
second-hand card something like eBay may
give you a ton of options from the 30
series and the 6000 series alike
including something like a 3080. some
quick pricing numbers all these are plus
or minus 20 bucks we just glanced at
Newegg into Amazon Amazon to get these
so the 4070 TI right now it's still
around 800 bucks plus or minus a bit the
40 70 is around 600 the 4060 TI is
around 400 and the 40 60 non-ti is 300.
for AMD if you haven't checked in a
while the 7900 XT has fallen in price
since launched it's about 800 bucks plus
or minus a bit now the 6950xc if you can
find it appears to be 630 but we really
didn't see many listings the 6900 XT
same situation that was about 600 6800
XT was 500 or so when we could find it
and then 6700 XT was about 330. so those
set up the key comparison points versus
the 6800 XT we're not going to go
through the spec sheet today we already
have a spec video on this if you want to
check it out we talk about it there the
main difference though is that this is a
cut CU count from the 6800 XT so the
difference there is 12 cus if you look
at amd's spec web page it's 60 versus
72. and that's going to contribute in
situate stations where architecture
alone and frequency changes can't pick
up for the 12cu difference because
technically one-to-one they're not
directly comparable there are changes
generationally but there's still an
advantage to those cus and we're going
to show you that today in our summary
chart especially for for some of the 4K
tests so that's enough setup we've got a
lot to go through today for data we have
compacted it a lot more than normally
though so the charts we speed run them
after we get through the first couple
let's get into it we'll start with star
field seeing as that's what we've spent
the last week testing at 4K High the
rx7800 XT ran at 48.7 FPS average with
lows at 37 and 27. those are paced
similarly to what we saw elsewhere this
game is kind of a mess for performance
but it's at least consistently a mess
and that's all that really matters for
benchmarking for current generation
flanks the RTX 4060 TI eight gigabyte
about 100 cheaper ran at 30.5 FPS
average that allows the 7800 XT El lead
of 60 percent a massive increase at a
cost of about 25 percent increase MSRP
to MSRP the 4070 is priced around 100
higher and lands at 39.5 FPS average
giving the 7800 XT a lead still of 23
percent while the 4070 is more expensive
than it in at least star field AMD is
currently in a strong lead we'll revisit
this as things patch and change to see
if that remains but for now at least
they're in a better starting point than
Nvidia and it may remain that way as for
more expensive options in this
particular title and with this game
version only the other AMD cards would
be worth considering the 7900 XT
improves by 32 percent at 64 FPS average
while costing around 790 to 820 or so
today finally as compared to the 6800 XT
which is a similar price if you can
still find one the 7800xc holds a lead
of about 10 percent the game may be
messy for performance but amd's relative
positioning is currently extremely
competitive for the 7800 XT in this
title at 14 40p High the 7800 XT ran at
79 FPS average with lows at 50 and 36.
that has it ahead of the 6800 XT by 10
percent so that much Remains the Same
the 7900 XT leads the 7800 XT by 22.5 in
this test down from 32 previously that's
because the 7900 XD is starting to hit a
CPU bottleneck so there'd be more room
to scale if not for that limiter
compared to Nvidia price competitors the
7800 XT leads the 4070 by 23 percent and
the 4060 TI by 62 percent scaling is
similar to the 4K high setting and AMD
is incredibly strong with its 7800 XT
positioning as compared to the 4070 and
the 4060 TI in this particular game we
have one more resolution before we see
how it does in other games at 1080p the
7800 XT was nearly an hour CPU bind the
7900 XT isn't present here because it's
irrelevant it's also CPU bound so uh
that alongside the 4090 and the 700 XTX
all look the same there's no room to
scale here so let's move to the next one
Dying Light 2 is new to our Benchmark
Suite started at 4K and with a custom
High configuration the 7800 XT ran at
45.7 FPS average with lows while timed
that has the 7800 XT as about 9.6 higher
frame rate than the 4070 it's about 39
higher than the 6700 XT and similarly
it's ahead of the 4060 TI the 6800 XT
ended up ahead of the 7800 XT
embarrassingly for AMD this time with a
12 lead that's more than just a partner
model difference it looks like amd's
choice is on the CU count may have
impacted it here as for the 4070 TI that
leads by 19 now for 1440p here the 7800
XT ran at 85.5 FPS average with frame
times again overall consistent and well
paced the 3080 leads followed by the
6800 XT which itself holds a lead over
the 7800 XT of 13 these companies it's
embarrassing what they're doing with
their naming scheme and it's amazing how
much less embarrassing the generational
losses would be both for NVIDIA and AMD
if they would just stop trying to trick
people into thinking the cards are worth
more than they are just by changing the
name at 1080p the rx7800 XT is 117 FPS
average still afforded the 6800 XT at 12
lead it's also about tied with the RTX
4070 including the lows compared to the
4060 TI the lead is about 30 here Andy's
biggest competition right now appears to
be itself from their perspective that's
probably not bad Resident Evil 4 is up
now another new game in our test suite
for this overhaul at 4K the 7800 XT ran
at 72 FPS average with frame times again
consistent this game appears to Pace
frames well for most of these cards the
rx6800 XT leads the 7800 XT Now by 6.2
percent and the 7800 XT ends up ahead of
the 4070 and roughly tied with the 3080
this time at 1440p the 7800 XT is 136
FPS average has it again just below the
1600 XT ahead of the 4070 by 9 and ahead
of the 6700 XT by a much larger 4 47
total Warhammer is up now at 4K of the
7800 XT sits at 56 FPS average with
relatively low one percent lows compared
to the gpus ahead of it the 7900 XT
leads by 39 at 78 FPS average with the
700 XTX about 70 the head as for other
gpus the lead over the 4060 TI is 44
establishing a strong position against
nvidia's recent launch the 4070 is tied
with the 7800 XT and all metrics for
this one with the 6800 XT a bit behind
but 4K is demanding for the 7800 XT
moving to 1440p the 1700 XT is 116 FPS
average has about four percent ahead of
the 40 70 in average FPS the 4060 TI is
far behind allowing a 44 lead to the
7800 XT as for the 6950 XT that one
establishes itself as a strong
alternative if you can grab one of the
last remaining jeeper models with a lead
of seven percent over the 7800 XT the
7900xc jumps 39 ahead with its 161 FPS
average so there is still a large Gulf
between amd's new GPU and its prior one
step down from Flagship option if they
were to do some type of refresh we'd
expect it to land in between these two
compared to the flanking 4070 TI the
7800 XT gives up a 20 lead to nvidia's
much more expensive 800 alternative
users of an RTX 2060 3060 or an AMD RX
5700 XT would probably find Value in an
upgrade here at 1080p the 7800 XT still
has plenty of CPU scaling Headroom to
take advantage of the 7900 XT has a 37
lead over the 78 XT with the 4070 about
tied within four percent of the new AMD
GPU the 4060 TI remains somewhat distant
and will be a better comparison to the
7700 XT in our next review video later
today last generation 6800 XT managed
nearly identical performance to the 78
XD with the 6950 XT pushing a little
further ahead once again if you're
wondering what the extra 300 gets you
from the Nvidia side the 47 70 TI would
yield again about a 20 uplift so not
great value comparatively in Tomb Raider
at 4K the rx7800 XT held a 93 FPS
average with frame times highly
consistent and well paced at 83 and 79.
that has it behind the 4070 on a
technicality but in reality they're
effectively tied the 6800 XT also leads
by a few percentage points with the 6950
XT a more notable 22 ahead the 470 TI
holds a similar lead here as well and
compared to cheaper options the 6700 XT
manages to achieve 74 of the performance
of the 7800 XT with a 4060 TI around the
same positioning moving to a 4070 TI or
7800 XT would gain you between 26
percent and 36 percent more performance
we're going to start going through these
charts a lot faster now just to sort of
rip through some numbers because we have
the foundation here and it's a pattern
at 1440p the 7800 XT moves to 167 FPS
average with frame times again
consistently timed the 4070 has a
tactical lead of two percent here with
the 470 TI more noteworthy at 23 again
while we're up here the 7900 XT keeps a
31 advantage over the new car cheaper
options like the 67 XT or the 4060 TI
are outpaced by the 78 XT by about 32
percent finally for Tomb Raider 1080p
has the 7800 XT at 223 FPS average
pushing the card close to the 7900 XT
due to external bottlenecks the CPU is
limited in the scaling room here so
everything north of 230 FPS is bound you
can ignore all of those results because
they're not scaling properly they are
restricted by other components the
growth over the 6700 XT was 25 here
Horizon zero Dawn is in briefly now and
this one the 7800 XT is 85 FPS average
had it functionally tied with the 6800
XT and the RTX 4070 including in frame
time pacing the lead over the 6700 XT
was 51 that's a generational jump but is
also technically by name a new SKU or
higher SKU and then there's a near
doubling of the 5700 xt's frame rate as
well as the other direction the 4070 TI
leads by 14 with the 700 XT ahead by
about 25 percent at 1440p the 7800 XT is
about tied with the 6800 XT it's ahead
of the 4070 by 3.9 percent it's ahead of
the 6700 xde by 42 percent and the 4060
TI by about the same once again we're
seeing about an 84 lead over the 5700 XT
so users of that GPU or the older 3060
or 2060 cards may see an opening for an
upgrade in this generation's modern
mid-range the hesitation there because
pricing has migrated quite a lot this
used to be considered high-end but it's
been a while 1080p didn't prove useful
for this game we were CPU bound so
moving up in Final Fantasy 14 at 4K the
7800 XT posted an 85 FPS average results
although the 0.1 percent lows are behind
where they should be this has been true
of amd's Hardware in general and the
current version of this testing process
for this specific game so it's not
unique to the 7800 XT there's already
added XC manages to lead the 6700 XT by
31 percent similar to the 1080 TI and
actually the 4060 TI the 4070 is ahead
of the 7800 XT and this one by about 6.8
percent and the 6800 XT pushes a little
higher still gaining 15 over the 7800 XT
as a final reference point toward the
top of this chart the extra money spent
on a 4070 TI would gain you 37 or so or
46 at the 700 XT level so better gains
than we've seen at the top end of this
than in some of these other games that
we've tested at 1440p the lows behave
the same way as we saw at 4K that's a
specific frame time pacing Behavior
again related to Final Fantasy 14's
Benchmark here the 7800 XT is 184 FPS
average has it ahead of the 46 TI by 28
and has the 4070 non-ti I had by five
percent the cards are becoming Limited
at the top of this chart allowing the
4070 TI to pull ahead but we're
bottlenecked on the CPU now so let's
move on Ray tracing is up now we're
keeping this brief since we just added a
bunch bunch of games to our test for
rasterization but we're adding more RT
testing in the next round to accompany
those changes starting with f122 at 4K
with rt on the 7800 XT ran about equal
to the 6800 XT it's not great for AMD
given that some of the prices of the
6800 XT lately especially if you go used
are fairly competitive with the new card
the 4070 has about a five percent lead
here so not much but our resolution is
also High let's move to 1440p at 1440p
with rt the rx7800 XT again roughly tied
with the 6800 XT it leads to the 4060 TI
by 18 with the 470 leading the 7800 XD
by 7 moving to Tomb Raider with rt
Shadows first at 4K the 7800 XT was tied
with the 68 XT the lead over the 4060 TI
is massive and that's due to the
resolution here that reduces and
compresses as the resolution also
reduces the 4070 maintains a five
percent lead here 1440p brings the low
lower end closer to the 7800 XT like the
4060 TI but it allows the 4070 to pull
ahead a little bit and grow its lead to
10 now otherwise the 6800 XT again is
about the same as the 7800 XT now for
power consumption the rx7800 XT pulled
248 Watts when stock and a full workload
overclocking it gave us Headroom up to
293 Watts that has the stock 248 watt
7800 XT as more efficient than for
example inthal's a750 nvidia's 290 watt
4070 TI tough that won by Asus pulled
more power but also ran a higher frame
rate than the 78 XT compared to the 6800
XT the 70 added XD consumed about 50
Watts less power in this workload all
right conclusions so again full
disclosure it's been an exhausting week
with the Starfield benchmarks plus this
so I have had to make things as simple
as possible because I need to sleep just
Frankly Speaking I think the editing
team can speak for me here uh so we're
going to defer to the new charts for
some numbers one important point with
these summaries first of all in
scenarios of a CPU bind like some of the
1080p tests for example you're not going
to see much change from card a to card B
that's normal that's because the cards
are limited by another component and so
that's not sort of the real number so if
you see a point two percent change where
everything else is 10 or 20 that's why
if it's 1080ps especially another point
is that this is we're trying to keep the
percent Math All in One Direction Where
possible just the math percent math is a
little funny so we mostly shoot for a
percent Improvement and that means in
the title of the chart it's going to say
from A to B that means from Baseline
card a so let's say a 7800 XT to a 6800
XT what is the percent Improvement going
that direction because that is actually
how this ended up working as you saw in
the video okay so this first chart is
for the 40 70 versus the 7800 XT and it
shows the percent improvement from the
4070 to the 78x meaning that the favor
is the 7800 XT here the 7800 XT
generally best at the 4070 sometimes in
large ways you see that particularly at
4K but we already know the 40 series
like with say the 4060 TI versus the
3060 TI has issues with these higher
resolutions but now the chart is flipped
this is with Ray tracing so now we're
looking at the change from the 7800 XT
to the 4070 when Ray traced the 4070 was
a clear winner it's anywhere from five
to fifteen percent better and these
charts 30 workloads we had another game
as well it's not on this chart but we're
adding a couple more Ray Trace games and
now that we've refreshed the rasterized
games this summary chart looks at the
improvement from the 7800 XT to the 6800
XT meaning that the bars going in the
positive direction to the right are the
percentage advantage that the 68 XT has
over the new 7800 XT and most of our
Tesla scenarios the 6800 XT bests the
7800 XT it's embarrassing by name at
least Fortune for AMD the 6800 XT had a
higher initial MSRP unfortunately for
AMD it's readily available for cheap if
used or in a couple places we checked
about the same price when new some of
the improvements are drastic like
strange Brigade Vulcan especially uh
like a 4K or Final Fantasy at 4K some
are more temperate here's the chart for
the 4060 TI to the 7800 XT in this one
the 7800 XT Has It by a mile sorry some
of you don't use the imperial system I
forgot about that uh for clarity a mile
is
7.99998 furlons hopefully that helps the
4060 TI loses by a lot to the 7800 XT
given the Well normally 100 price Gap
but the 16 gigabyte one is like the same
price nvidia's 4060 TI therefore seems
to be exactly where we left it which is
the trash if nothing else the 7800 XT
has at least proven that
the 16 gigabyte version of the 4060 TI
which is the same card just with more
memory is probably one of the worst
possible values you could buy right now
or maybe any time in the last couple
years outside of things like Titan class
cards for gaming so uh that that hasn't
changed the 4060 TI still doesn't make
much sense the 6800xc is pretty
compelling if you can still find it
that's the problem though
um hopefully it helps you make a
decision though you've got all the
numbers we wanted to package these
results as neatly as we could in an
approachable fashion we don't normally
display things this way so hopefully you
like it and uh if not too bad we're
gonna keep doing them anyway but we're
going to keep iterating on it to add
some more games to it as things go and
the biggest thing that happens here is
NVIDIA gets eviscerated and
rasterization just in general for
pricing or value right now when looking
at the 4060 TI of the 4070 even we
expect something also to slide in
between the 7900 XT and the 7800 XT that
seems like maybe it's supposed to be the
7800 GRE but that's not an official
launch so amd's still got a large gap in
its pricing range but recently uh AMD
did state that it's done launching gpus
for this generation with new Asics that
kind of leaves some wiggle room for a
refresh but this would be the place we'd
expect to see one if they make one
definitely an embarrassing showing as
compared to the 6800 XT though which is
again about the same price right now so
we just say buy that instead if you can
if you're shopping in this price class
it's a good guard now our main concern
with the 78 XD has been that
underperformance versus the 6000 series
it's more power efficient on a
technicality well it depends which game
you look at but generally speaking it's
more power efficient it's just it's
underperforming versus what the naming
would suggest and we saw that with the
4060 TI versus the 3060 TI yeah the
problem it comes down to marketing they
want to have their cake and eat it too
they want to be able to call it a higher
end card than it is but they don't want
to make it a higher end car they just
want the money for it
um so you know this one
it's at least positioned competitively
with with Nvidia right now that's the
thing that we like about it compared to
a 4070 especially compared to a 4060 TI
and absolutely compared to a 4060 TI 16
gigabyte this is competitively
positioned Andy has done well on the
pricing standpoint to get there RT is a
different different story but that much
is better but as long as some of these
other cards like 68 XDS are still on the
market you really should look into those
see if the pricing makes sense for you
depends a lot on region and if you're
okay with use we really would encourage
you to explore those options because now
more than ever there's there's just so
many used options on the market you take
some risk with that you might save a lot
of money though for more power all right
you've got the numbers we're gonna let
you make the decision on this one and
we're gonna roll onto the 7700 XT review
we've got some more to think about and
talk about for the differences with
these cards uh and that'll be next so
check back for that as always subscribe
for more go to store.com access.net
helps out directly or patreon.com Gamers
Nexus to help fund my benchmarking
addiction we'll see you all in the next
one